he's a near unstoppable force of evil so
dangerous that on multiple occasions
spider-man and venom have been forced to
set aside their differences to put an
end to his wrath let's take a look at
the chaotic mind and twisted motivations
of carnage one of marvel's deadliest
villains carnage is a product of the
bonds between a member of the symbiotic
alien race known as ceclinta and cletus
cassidy a deranged serial killer who
pushed his own grandmother down a flight
of stairs as a child cassidy was sent to
an orphanage which he burned down so he
developed a lust for pure chaos and
mayhem long before he ever came into
contact with the symbiote so when
artists eric larson and mark bagley were
seeking inspiration for the character's
appearance and traits they didn't have
to look far writer david mcelini
conceived of carnage as the closest
thing to an irredeemably malevolent
force as could exist in the marvel
universe so the artist modeled cassidy
on the joker who has long filled just
such a role in the dc universe i'm a dog
chasing cars i wouldn't know what to do
with one if i caught it
you know i just do things
eddie brock separated from his venom
symbiote and sent to prison for his
crimes was cassidy's cellmate while
waiting for the symbiote to spring him
brock developed an antagonistic attitude
toward the depraved cassidy beating him
mercilessly on more than one occasion
the venom symbiotes did eventually
manage to free brock but in the process
it spawned a new symbiote leaving it
behind in cassidy's cell this
technically makes carnage venom sun and
like the contentious bond brock shares
with venom in which the two sometimes
duel for control carnage sees its
relationship with cassidy as much more
than symbiotic it entered cassidy's body
through a curt so the symbiote was able
to bond with his bloodstream making the
two extremely difficult to separate
unlike venom carnage does not refer to
itself as we it's one entity venom's
hatred of carnage is so intense that it
even overrides his hatred of spider-man
and as far as carnage is concerned the
feeling is mutual
it might be tough to separate carnage
from cassidy but it has happened a few
times and when it has carnage had no
problem bonding with other hosts it's
unempowered victims through the
multiverse have included gwen stacy john
jameson and dr tannis diedes a
psychiatrist of carnage's girlfriend
shriek carnage has also bonded with
superpowered people a truly terrifying
proposition for one it bonded with ben
reilly spider-man at the time to create
spider carnage a symbiote also once
briefly bonded with the extremely
powerful silver surfer to become carnage
cosmic in one of peter parker's worst
nightmares come true carnage also once
bonded with norman osborne the green
goblin to become the red goblin already
greatly enhanced by his goblin serum
osborne became exponentially more
powerful with carnage obsessed not just
with killing spider-man but crushing his
very soul the goblin threatened to
slowly and painfully kill everyone peter
held dear unless he gave up his
crime-fighting ways after a brawl that
left the daily bugle officers in
shambles and flash thompson dead parker
revealed his desperation by allowing the
venom symbiote to bond with him for one
last shuttered victory over the red
goblin on the brink of death peter was
able to convince osborne that carnage
not the goblin would get all the credit
for killing spider-man driven by ego
osborne shredded the symbiotes which led
to the villain's sound defeat klintar
are generally indifferent or
antagonistic toward their offspring and
carnage is no exception during the brief
time the symbiote was in control of doug
dunhams it used her to find cassidy
abandoning her for his original host but
leaving a spawn behind growing on her
arm horrified nieves took drastic action
and cut her ram off but symbiotes don't
give up easily and it eventually
rebonded with her to become the heroic
scorn who has been a thorn in the side
of her father on multiple occasions
another of carnage's offspring was
outright rejected carnage disgusted and
enraged by its spawn implanted it into
new york police officer paddy mulligan
during a chance encounter resolving to
kill it before it could reach maturity
carnage attacked mulligan and his family
but was foiled by spider-man and black
cat mulligan tracked the cat down for
answers but the pair once again came
under attack by carnage this time the
new symbiote made its presence known
calling itself toxin it single-handedly
took down carnage and venom and resolved
to become a hero the virtuous mulligan
had trouble containing the symbiote's
homicidal urges however and after the
officer was killed in battle toxin
briefly bonded with eddie brock and
finally with brent waters
venom and carnage have battled countless
times with the latter's superior
strength usually giving him the upper
hand but venom has often outsmarted him
at one point cassidy was being held in a
special prison designed to contain
carnage when venom paid his son a visit
cassidy could only jibber helplessly as
venom ripped the symbiote from his body
and devoured it cassidy escaped and
attempted to resume his reign of terror
by painting himself red and embarking on
yet another killing spree as a makeshift
carnage he was easily defeated by
spider-man but cassidy was given new
hope a failed invasion of earth by the
interdimensional beings of the negative
zone reactivated dormant traces of the
symbiote within his bloodstream finding
his way through a portal to the negative
zone cassidy was mysteriously guided to
a second symbiote apparently identical
to his first and enthusiastically
allowed it to bond with him becoming
carnage once again
during the events of the avengers x-men
axis crossover events the moral
alignment of a number of heroes and
villains were magically switched this
had a profound effect on carnage who
found himself saddled with an
overwhelming desire to help people and
do good despite having literally no idea
how he abducted local reporter alice
gleason to tutor him in the ways of
being a hero after barely restraining
him from killing a couple of random
thugs but even under her strict guidance
carnage tended to get his wires crossed
for example when carnage and alice came
across a bank being robbed the symbiote
heroically thwarted the robbery before
attempting to burn down the bank to
prevent future robberies while
apparently developing romantic feelings
for alice carnage was constantly
distracted by fantasies of her dying
during a climactic battle in new york
carnage apparently sacrificed himself
for the good of the city but of course
such deaths are almost always temporary
in the marvel universe and it wouldn't
be long before cassidy appeared once
again back to his old homicidal ways
marvel's ultimate line of comics which
began publication in 2000 updated some
of its most popular characters and
storylines for a new generation of
readers it took place in a different
continuity than the mainstream marvel
universe and while it has now defunct
some of its more popular original
characters namely miles morales managed
to survive the destruction of their home
universe and have come over to the main
marvel you
some spider-man
i'm not the only one
in the ultimate universe symbiotes
weren't an alien race instead they were
the results of a genetic experiment by
peter parker's father richard and eddie
brock senior the first of these
symbiotes was venom and this
relationship to peter and eddie jr
played out much the same way it did in
the main continuity carnage however was
created in a lab by dr kurt connors who
had the bright idea to combine some of
peter's dna with a sample of venom along
with his own lizard mutated dna the
result was a fearsome beast which could
only survive by feeding on humans and
was obsessed with consuming spider-man
to complete its dna sequence it even ate
gwen stacy then created an exact genetic
replica of her to serve as its host this
version of carnage was itself eventually
consumed by venom
on a couple of the rare occasions in
which marvel has teamed up with rival
publisher dc for crossovers carnage has
been involved he notably teamed up with
his inspiration the joker for the 1995
one shot spider-man and batman
disordered mines the team up was
short-lived although they seemed like
the perfect evil pairing carnage butted
head to the clown prince of crime early
and often due to the joker's tendency
towards theatrics and his own preference
for 110 slaughter carnage found the
joker's methods to be tedious and
unsatisfying or the joker found carnage
to be a hack carnage also made his
presence known in the amalgam line of
comics an imprint in which marvel and dc
heroes and villains were combined to
create a new mash of characters carnage
was matched up with superman nemesis
pizarro to create bizanitch the creature
wreaked indiscriminate havoc until it
was eventually tricked and defeated by
spiderboy himself a mashup of spider-man
and superboy
karna just surprised cameo in the 2018
venom feature film promised that
there's gonna be carnage
it raised the character's profile so
marvel brought him back to the comics
page with a web of venom carnage born
one shot its story deals with a cult
attempting to resurrect the villain
after his death in the venomous
storyline and if that's not dark enough
it's implied cassidy was a cannibal
before fusing with a symbiote the issue
solicitation states a cruel cannibal
obsessed with death and murder few
mourned cletus cassidy after he
seemingly died in venomized with the
second venom movie subtitled let there
be carnage it's no surprise that marvel
comics has given us a revamped and even
darker version of the character though
it should be noted carnage had some
pretty dark comics appearances well
before venom that debbie carnage is
primed to give us a cinematic villain
for the aegis and it certainly doesn't
hurt that the great woody harrelson is
filling the role
carnage has starred in plenty of
mini-series one-shots and even line-wide
events based on his bloody exploits
but the release of 2016's carnage issue
1 gave the craze symbiote his first
ongoing monthly series it also marks the
marvel return of writer jerry conway his
first work on a regular marvel series
since the 90s the series finds the title
villain lord to grey ridge mine with
manuela calderon the sole survivor of
cletus cassidy's very first mass killing
as bait but when the owner of the mine
turns out to have his own agenda carnage
and some of the agents tasked with
capturing him fall into the mine
calderon eddie brock john jameson and
fbi special agent claire dixon followed
carnage into the depths where a strange
cult called the dark holders wait with
their own plans most of the series 16
issues revolve around an unexpected
mystical and prophetic connection
between carnage and an ancient
lovecraftian god before the end carnage
gets a power boost and one of the heroes
chasing him becomes part of the violent
symbiote family
in the venom series that debuted in 2018
it's revealed that the klintar symbiotes
are not just an alien species but
parasites created by the eldritch guard
null to do his bidding so after the cult
of null resurrects carnage in weber
venom carnage born they reveal that
every human on earth to ever bomb with a
symbiote as what they call a codex
embedded in their dna if carnage
collects all these codexes he will
become the vessel for null on earth and
be able to conquer the world after a lot
of bloodshed including the deaths of a
superhero or two venom kills cletus in
2020s absolute carnage issue 5 but in
doing so ensures the eventual assault on
earth by null venom has to resolve that
in the kingdom black event where carnage
plays only a small role
carnage became a meal for sharks in
carnage black white and blood but
extreme carnage issue 1 reveals that a
piece of the symbiote survived at the
bottom of the ocean it bonds with a fish
and works its way up the chain to
eventually bond with xenophobic senator
peter crane who's seeking an end to her
bring any and all extraterrestrial
aliens on u.s soil carnage uses senator
crane's voice to seize the wills of
various symbiotes over the television
airways standing against them are flash
thompson now agent anti-venom and andy
benton the former host of the symbiote
scream after crippling a symbiote with
hellfire to stop it from following
carnage's orders she rebonds with an
alternate version of the symbiote now
calling itself silence
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite marvel characters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one